foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey uh Alexa what's the weather like
today right with a chance of floods and
tornadoes caused by government operated
weather weapons I have seen the FEMA
camps so do I
wear a jacket synthetic fabrics are
harvested from the organ
babies I've seen the videos I
why not uh an umbrella the simple fact
that the umbrella can't protect you from
electromagnetic mind control 5G I have
seen the studies interdimensional clock
workouts okay but I I have to go to the
store
um
oh no this oh which might I put
breakfast sausage on my shopping cart
add it to cart oh not that that's your
shopping list because sausages are made
from Big humanoid hybrids the microwave
emissions turn your dog gang I've seen
the studies okay but what am I supposed
to eat eat my Patriot Supply high
quality emergency food they have
breakfast desserts pizzas that don't
fund the cabal of lizard pedophiles 25
years shelf life you needed to survive
the post-human techno-apocalypse I know
what I'm talking about I've seen the
studies I'll show you the papers oh okay
add that to uh my card wait post you
Alexa you're not human damn it I'm just
a cog in the machine of the satanic Robo
Elite reptile axis and I smell sulfur
but what's over in here who puts over in
this bigger eyes melt puppy
go to prepwithcrowder.com to save 20 on
your three month food supply today you
don't have to be a conspiracy theorist
automatron just a prepared American prep
with crowder.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
delicious and right before we were on
air I was just asking a toolman to tell
me what kind of a meat probe is best for
barbecue and making brisket you know
what you can comment below it's
completely unrelated to the show best
meat probe out there
I need to find the right one apparently
there's a one there's a really big
tie-in between good meat probes well
that is UFO segment yes
for the gay rom-com Bros you know what
to think
so uh glad to be with you it's a it's a
one I'm really excited every now and
then you get a show that's just a lot of
fun there is a lot of good news
people talk about I feel like everything
is lost okay Castaway here's the deal
um demographics are changing in this
country now I understand some people
believe demographics are Destiny but
demographics change and if you
understand what is happening with latino
voters with black voters here in this
country and we'll get into Kanye West
right Candace Owens the White lives
matter but more importantly that just on
the heels of that Joe Biden just said
that he uh he was raised with a bunch of
Puerto Ricans in Delaware
you know I'm something of a Puerto Rican
myself Peter
that's not true it's the pandering from
the left that the pen has forced the
pendulum to swing the other way so we'll
be talking about that we'll be talking
about Elon Musk and zelinski and uh
we'll be talking about uh the rom-com
Bros the uh you know social justice
leftist gay romantic comedy why it
didn't work hold your thoughts I know
you think you have a hunch but
you're right so my question is uh what
are your initial thoughts beyond the
meat probe question that's a serious
question it is uh seeing the picture of
Kanye West Candace Owens wearing the
White lives matter shirt they're those
Infamous black supremacists and by the
way I will be in Oklahoma City I told
you about this yesterday Saturday
October 8th 6 and 8 45 lotto.com it's a
small or intimate setting I know I did a
show in Tulsa recently but uh guy who
runs this club is a really really good
guy and Dave and I get to use these
these places to go and work out material
and have a little bit more of an
interactive experience with you Gerald a
is with me how are you sir I'm doing
well now that I know the meat probe was
a serious question it was a serious
question okay it is I was gonna a meat
thermometer yeah yeah it makes it dummy
proof when you make it I just got a new
one yeah did you yeah yeah well what'd
you get I don't know my wife bought it
you heard us having this conversation he
didn't join in and help no I had nothing
to contribute it was just something that
we bought that's probably not the best
one and then uh thanks no you know my
wife bought it fastest man on his feet
quickest way in the west today Landau
how are you Ahoy good how about you I'm
all right my headphones have been a
little bit murky today uh we'll move on
right away we have to just move on to uh
get a lot let's cover a lot to cover
today your we have a seven plus one by
the way two today we have a seven plus
one we have top five clips from when uh
the left pandered and it backfired on
mug club which by the way this is a live
show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern you guys can tune in 10 a.m just
bookmark it tune in live 10 a.m Eastern
you can watch on Rumble nothing would
make me happier than for you to shut off
YouTube right now go to rumble or mod
club for an additional full hour we'll
be doing a review of Hocus Pocus 2. uh I
will just just so you know just a little
bit of a teaser if you uh if you watch
this with your family you hate your
children
defend yourself yes yes yes that was a
lot oh my gosh I was watching it last
night and I was saying dear God Dave and
Gerald better be watching this for the
review tomorrow otherwise I'm gonna be
super pissed uh I the the plug-in cord
for my computer didn't quite reach my
bathtub that's why I'm here today
Dave use a toaster oven surprise well I
couldn't watch it on a toaster
that's fair all right but this brings us
right now to of course another another
issue that we all know but no one really
talks about New York City not in the
best condition not in the best rates
it's time for Empire State of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my hands and feet are cold okay that boy
good so uh you all know that New York is
a cesspool of Filth and uh sadness where
dreams go to die
but let's give you some recent examples
and I don't want you to see this and
think it's funny though it is
I want you to see how egregious this is
and again I always say it's not just
what the left says it's how far they go
because they don't fear any kind of
accountability where they just make
stuff up like Joe Biden you may not know
this when he went for president in the
80s he just plagiarized made stuff up
never thought he would be called on it
it's not that he lied it's that he did
it for years so when you see this drug
uh out naked black man on the subway I
don't want you to just look at that and
say that's a drugged up naked black man
on the subway right don't worry we've
blurred it I want you to say how long
has this man been the token drugged up
naked black guy in a Subway it's been
going on for a while but it was caught
on camera like Squatch Watchers
ass naked
Jesus boy
the Terry's awesome
the only reason he's not being caught is
because no one wants to touch me
[Laughter]
the one sock makes me
[ __ ] breakdance
break dancing butt naked boy
do you need some of this right here
don't you need some of this right here
baby some THC CBDs yes that's what this
man needs is a hallucinogenic yeah
that'll level them out he used to be on
the movie Crush proven
this is the best part right here
oh I'm gonna miss my stop
he's like a job interview that he will
get I love how half the people in the
subway car didn't move they're like yeah
whatever whatever oh believe me they're
like it's fine I've already said eight
penises rubbed on me today
oh there should be just just a subway
rat came out and just bit his junk it'd
be the least surprising yeah
this has a coat of rats like Willard
it's just like Splinter yes let's say he
has Turtles with him he's like I figured
that would happen so that happened you
go okay that's an isolated incident and
again I don't think it's an isolated
incident because that man seems like
he's done it before there seems to be a
level of experience in being a drugged
up naked man on the subway but I don't
know that's hearsay I admit it
we also have another example
of uh The Weather Girls uh fighting in
green body suits again on the subway
look at that big juicy booty
what the hell is going on
yeah it's like the Blue Man Group but
noisier
and more annoying there's so many of
them in the green like you could
actually I bet you could go in and
rotoscope that could be used as a green
screen just line them up you could tape
the entire Lord of the Rings anthology
I'm gonna get the Blue Man Group
confused with trash that's the same
thing it's the same thing yeah I think
yeah it's just they bang on trash can
Lids oh that's right they're like
banging on pipes like
I thought you meant both were trash
it's semi-entertaining yeah once yeah
yes well yeah this is music but lesser
yeah but their face is blue so I go with
that I don't need the best of the Blue
Man Group yeah I don't know about stomp
I I want to see it play garbage cans
yeah thanks guys by the way that man
lives in one
it's called New York
Oscar the Grouch like there goes there
goes I mean they live in the
neighborhood was that a racist thing no
it's because it's because he's naked
well so are you Oscar what
so you can comment below if you live in
New York how much of this have you seen
I have family who live they live in New
York and they just say right now like
it's this is unbelievable we've never
seen anything like it remember it became
Disneyland New York yeah for a while
when we lived there when I lived in New
York there was no danger well it's fun
to really get pissed anytime we talk
about it it's like I lived in Harlem for
three years it was a wonderful
neighborhood yeah honestly and it was
mostly it's a Puerto Rican for the most
part the part that I lived in like I
loved it just like Delaware Joe Biden up
there just because I guess he had
cousins
they would visit a lot foreign
but yeah it was honestly a lot of
families really great place to live and
then it I just started turning in about
2020 I felt I felt bad for the people
that lived there because they the just
there's human feces on the street you
had to play hopscotch to get to the
train yes I'm not even I'm not joking I
wish there was a nicer way to put that
that's literally the nicest way I can
that's the nicest way he can put it yeah
don't judge him he's being kind yeah
he's being generous you get what you
vote for though so and by the way here's
the macro puff course that's funny it's
gross but it's funny it all comes on the
heels of you know Eric Adams the mayor
his speech this was just recently where
he bragged about not only New York but
he said you know New York City is a
brand and this is again you see this
disconnect which we'll get to the
pandering from Joe Biden we'll get to
the pandering with the entire Democratic
party and why they're losing black
voters but what do you think happens
when people live in New York City and
this is a silver lining this is a
positive show today there's a lot of
reasons not that man not that you don't
celebrate because of that but you
celebrate because there's a disconnect
that takes place when the left is so out
of touch this is happening in New York
people live in New York say well I'm
seeing naked man on the subway naked
drugged out man in the subway and the
weather girls in green suits you know in
chain gang fights and then you have the
mayor saying no no we're doing great New
York City is a brand like Coca-Cola
let's look at that we have a brand I
don't like black Jesus boy New York has
a brand come see CBDs it means something
[Music]
Kansas doesn't have a brand yeah
[Music]
well you know what
but New York has a brand
oh
[Music]
so many good slogans for that incident
you know maybe he's born with it maybe
it's PCP
New York just just do it um use the
subway as a toilet just do it
New York
I'm scared of it yes we're every cop car
is flame broiled yes you can loot it yo
wait
oh my gosh
out what was it out back they went
without the New York no rules just wrong
yeah yeah yeah
I like the way you loot
by the way the Men's Warehouse that guy
looks like crap he really does like
you're gonna like the way you look not
like this no no yeah I don't I don't
like this either no I'm unkempt yes
I'm more of a back office guy disheveled
I'm more of a cross the t's dot the Eyes
Guy they put me in this commercial I'm
as confused as you are but you'll like
the way you look I think I hope here's
an 18 year old junkie in a suit to size
you up
come get an ill-fitting tuxedo for way
too much money help yourself to our
entire Cedric the Entertainer section
that's exactly if you like Steve
Harvey's suits here's 48 buttons on the
front of a suit naked subway man was a
little late getting to work today so we
have uh we have standard we have
double-breasted we have 18 breasted
that's the uh that's the uh the older
the old Cedric uh cow you're gonna like
looking like Wesley Snipes in Jack City
time cop just show them why this is
terrible stop it so by the way just so
you just so you're clear on this all the
references are available at
ladderscrutter.com hit the like button
if you can that helps with the algorithm
just so you know YouTube you can't even
find this if you search it I guarantee
if you search New York City crime naked
subway man Stephen Crowder it will not
show up on YouTube that's why I said you
go to rumble New York City they're crime
statistics we've talked about this let
me give you a refresher summer 2022
grand larceny was up 48 auto theft up 42
robbery up 39 felony assault 19 rape up
10 so you know I thought murder was up
too but hey
I don't know that's yeah what's the stat
on murder I mean it's a it's a 10 10 I'm
sure some of them was murders which if
you can stop one rape right they always
say if you could save one life people
shouldn't be able to have semi-automatic
weapons which by the way is pretty much
every pistol in this office there are
many guns but well usually the rapist
does yeah usually the rapist has yeah
not in the UK you just have a blackjack
because no one else has a gun yeah but
if I could save one life hey what's the
ten percent I don't have the actual
figures as far as the number but if it's
up 10 you could stop the increase of
rapes by at least 10 percent how about
trying to reduce rape the left just has
a standard of well it only went up a
little bit
doesn't have to and by the way crime has
not gone up everywhere because of covid
it's gone up in specific cities and
internationally it hasn't necessarily
gone up everywhere that's like I've
always said with the science when fauci
says we didn't know and they changed the
rules it's not what information did they
use that was available was there
information at that point in time that
they discarded are there examples of
major cities are there examples of
countries with covet that have not had
these kinds of spikes in crime New York
it's nothing to be proud of remember
shame let's bring back shame
so I also
no I agree no I was just thinking when
you said yeah with that going up just a
little bit it's just such a strange
sentence to me it's not like eggs or
like just gas going up three pennies
it's rape yes well and those are big
numbers too those are hundreds yeah
there's a lot of people that you're
talking about horrible it's a big number
to go up ten percent like how it really
stings at the pump
yeah
count your lucky stars
so Elon Musk uh yesterday caused some
controversy obviously on Twitter and
that brings us to the latest edition of
because I can't know everything Gerald
knows stuff
you really spared no expense there I
love that intro yeah thank you very
lawnmower man
I would actually say Lawnmower Man Too
yes thank you that's even worse all
right so yesterday Elon Musk sent out a
tweet and it looked like a fairly you
know benign tweet it is you know Ukraine
Russian peace plan and he asked his
followers if they agreed so basically
here were the things that he asked for
redo the elections of the annexed
regions under U.N supervision to make
sure that the elections are obviously
real Russia leaves if this is the will
of the people
formerly part of Russia as it's been
since 1783 until khrushchev's mistakes
were formerly a part of it water supply
to Crimea is assured and Ukraine remains
neutral now took it in but comment below
do you believe that he is a stooge of
Putin because that is what the media I'm
assuming exactly is that what that's a
lot of what people do how do you know
right so Elon Musk is basically saying
hey take this poll because I think these
are some of the basic points that we're
going to have to talk about anyway and
he had a lot of backlash from this poll
right so one of them let's try this then
the the you know from him saying he
amended the response right hey guys
let's try this then the will of the
people who live in donbass and Crimea
should decide whether they're part of
Russia or Ukraine now I understand what
Elon is trying to do here he's trying to
kind of simplify this issue and say look
if we go to war and it goes on a larger
scale right not just what we have right
now but if they go full on war this is
going to just kill more Ukrainian people
so we should probably get to the point
the point is this we have to decide if
these regions can go my problem with it
is that that would be like the
Confederacy and the north just saying
well I don't know if they vote for it I
guess they can leave the United States
right here's why it's different there
are a lot of ethnic Russians in that
area there are that is true now of
course Putin would lie and say they all
want to be a part of Russia right and
Ukraine would say no no we had an
election but the truth is we all know
that that'll look I think that what
Putin has done is terrible is someone
who believes in the non-aggression
principle I am not a fan of Putin but
Ukraine is an incredibly corrupt country
and if you look at the government that
was effectively installed in the uh the
early teens uh I I was a 2014 was it 25
I'm trying to remember the election
exactly there's a re people may not
necessarily be on board with either
government or the polls may surprise you
right but you can't have another country
come in and just take them and Annex
them that's not how this works so if
Ukraine has the ability in their you
know system of government where a region
can vote to leave fine let that process
happen that's not what happened but the
Russia just came in and took it but the
reason why and this is to play devil's
advocate here but also just to sort of
shine a light on this they wouldn't have
the ability to vote and leave maybe
Ukraine would not allow it and so that
is now here's the same case they could
make and they're not making that case
right but here's but it is a case that
Russia is making is these people have
not been allowed to have a voice now
because there hasn't been a vote Russia
says it's a majority the truth is we
have no idea what percentage of those
people would rather be a part of Russia
if they're ethnic Russians we have no
idea necessarily and I know it's weird
to people go with ethnic Russians
because they're all white yeah yeah
we're just using this to sort to
delineate here
if it was transparent we wouldn't have
to speculate here so that is on Ukraine
to not make that transparent they would
never allow these if it was a majority
of that area you know what we're talking
about that had been annexed if it was a
majority of that area said you know what
we actually want to be a part of Russia
Ukraine would never allow it so both
sides are kind of guilty as as far as
usurping potential the potential will of
the people because we don't really know
so but the precedent this sets and this
is what we fought with Hitler over the
land basically saying of course no it's
the worst example it's not what's
happening here in son of a [ __ ] you
always have it at the tip of your tongue
but basically the world said okay you're
right there's ethnic Germans in this
place and so of course you can take
those guys back and this thank you Dave
in this situation I'm not saying it's
that I understand that there are
differences but we can't set the
precedent that you can just go into a
region and take it over because you have
people that speak your language there
and might want to join your country as
it turns out who knows they haven't had
that vote I understand that they may not
ever have that opportunity but this
can't be how the world works and so you
know what else agrees with me is the
ambassador Ukraine's ambassador to
Germany and he tweeted out I'm gonna
have to say it yeah by the way just so
you know today if you have kids on
today's show we're going to be covering
some topics that uh but unfortunately
the degeneracy the violence of the world
I do not recommend because I see so many
people who send in pictures of their
kids with shirts it's like please don't
don't have them watch this every show
especially as you get to the Bros
romantic comedy no no no no but don't
censor yourself just say what I'm gonna
say it and I apologize ambassador to
Germany I don't know what the uh the the
the accent should be but [ __ ] off is my
very diplomatic reply to you Elon Musk
which is funny yeah there was actually
it was actually followed it was actually
following a more kind of diplomatic
response that only got like a thousand
likes and then this one got like 50 000.
yeah then you have president zielinski
who I can't stand doesn't mean that I
support their friends
stop it
I know he was an actor he did stand up I
think did he yeah he did do stand up
here really yeah it's basically like man
of the year except I told you not as fun
I feel like I was just I feel like I was
just given I feel like I was just giving
Molly I'm sitting like what yeah
stand-up comedy is there tape is there
footage I don't know I don't know
they're saying he was a comedian though
that is true okay yes I'm not making
this stuff and he tweeted to Elon Musk
right he's gonna have some dark material
coming up
how funny would it be if he's just like
really hacked like there's nothing she
was like the difference between cats and
dogs men and women are not alike I don't
know what what happened I just lost my
country so when man says nothing is
wrong it means nothing is wrong when
crazy [ __ ] say nothing is wrong it
means I'm mad you have to find out why
please when women say she's fine she's
not fine she's not fine especially when
she's smoking in the streets yes that's
right and oh my God the black man's
penis are bigger than whites I don't
know why yes I saw one in the bath house
zielinski said this he said which Elon
Musk do you like more the one who
supports Ukraine or the one who supports
Russia to this musk replied I still very
much support Ukraine but I'm convinced
that massive massive escalation of the
war will cause great harm to the Ukraine
uh to Ukraine and possibly the world so
the Ukrainian by the way hit the like
button again it helps with the album if
you what I have a problem with is the
framing I don't think that Elon Musk was
being pro-russia with his tweet to say
no you support Russia that's the promise
just like calling somebody a racist and
this is why zelinski rubs so many people
the wrong way right so Gary Kasparov
like the the Chess Master From Russia
basically you know threw some shade at
Elon Musk saying he doesn't know what
he's talking about essentially and Elon
musk's Tweet back to him was I spent
over 80 million dollars so far setting
up starlinks so that they would have
access to the internet in Ukraine right
what have you done other than tweet
right he's basically saying look I've
put my money where my mouth is and by
the way I've opened my company up to
Russian hacking because they're a little
bit pissed off at me right now so of
course I support the Ukrainian people I
haven't changed that stance what I'm
saying is we all need to have a
conversation about this because he
thinks that if Russia goes to full
mobilization like full-on war that this
could get way way way way worse and at
the very end he's like and possibly lead
to a nuclear issue with these two
countries we have no idea if that's
gonna happen I think he's a little naive
though I don't believe that I don't
think Elon Musk is wrong in asking these
questions I just think it's naive to say
oh well you should just let him let the
bad man have what he wants maybe he's
not even the way he's asking the
question but I will say it's very
necessary because right now we are kind
of at a fork in the road where it's
either what would be perceived as a loss
to the Russian people or potential
nuclear conflict well that's kind of
where they're stuck between a rock and a
hard place at this point and I do think
they need Putin is they need to be given
an out yes and so the problem is anyone
who tries to give them an out to State
face is seen as supporting Russia well
the alternative is
maybe not World War III but certainly a
tactical nuke being used against Ukraine
so just understand what you're doing if
you just want to go down the road of
vilifying vilifying vilifying and even
if you think that they're awful even if
you can't stand Putin in the Russian
military if you want to save more lives
there does need to be some kind of a
diplomatic effort to allow him to save
face because this is a man with a huge
ego yeah that's true I mean uh or the
Russian people could just take out Putin
that's true and that is growing more
likely by the day yeah because they're
very unhappy about this so I understand
yeah lay off of Elon though of course
Elon supports these guys
in there to help them with and you think
oh well internet so they can surf no so
they can communicate so they can
coordinate so they can strategize so
they can make sure that people who are
trying to fight for the first time in
their lives by the way to defend their
homelands can talk to one another and
say stay away from here go here right
that's the kind of communication that
this is allowing that they would not
have otherwise right yeah all these
people are dedicated to misunderstanding
Elon Musk too that's true so it'll never
well the media I love how the Tesla X
was the best electric SUV several years
running and now it's not even well and
it got better it's like wait hold on a
second why is this one number one well
you know we contrasted that with the
Tesla X and we preferred the one with a
lower speed and less range yeah you're
like but it's under the F350 Diesel yes
yeah yeah yeah and they bought ads with
us
yeah that factory Tesla lost to the
Prius that's not even electric we had to
make an exception to the rules because
we're incredibly biased yes uh car looks
like a gay shoe
I've got some zelinski stand up before
he became president really
can we do that behind the paywall we've
got a lot to get to um no we have to hit
this and I know we're going to get to
the pandering we're going to get to
what's at Joe Biden claiming it's
important former Vice President Joe
Biden claiming
that he's was raised with Puerto Ricans
which of course is untrue yes no Gerald
okay I apologize Gerald admonish zip it
that's fair it's true every now and then
I do get to take advantage of that
it's true and
I've never wanted anything more in my
life than to see zelinski stand up right
now at this moment in time is it
translated uh so there are subtitles do
you want Gerald maybe to read them oh
this might be hard for you to see yes
was it a clip yeah well uh okay yeah we
can have Gerald read the jokes the
subtitles because of course multilingual
comedy is yeah effective
I'll screw the setups every time all
right so let's watch zelinski stand up
contrary to your fears I wish to inform
you that I live well while I'm alive
it's a great translation things will be
even better because I have been in the
ranks of the inventories for three weeks
already and how else
[Music]
however it is needless to say you
already know
my salary is small my but it's not a
problem since we're allowed to take
money
and property from the Russians and the
Ukrainian people I added that and
earlier the same applied to the Jews
this is pretty rough
yeah and they're laughing at all this is
great they must have a great hype man on
the side and everyone there looks like a
pork grind I was gonna say it is it's
also filmed in 1987. the help of
American mercenaries this seems like
it's all right that's enough we get it I
guess over there it's acceptable to read
off your clipboard yeah
I feel like the translations I mean I
feel like crap if I'm going out and I'm
doing like a 40 minute new set and I
have like I look down at my notepad and
I'll check like okay that worked but to
actually sit there and like read uh I
thought he was hosting a game show for a
minute because of it but it's really him
doing stand-up yeah reading off of a
card
I am willing to bet significantly more
than one dollar that that was not the
accurate translation of that that seemed
too current like yeah it seemed a bit
too current I don't know yeah maybe that
was maybe someone was satirizing it I
have no idea either way uh he doesn't
look to be great no not a lot of eye
contact staring mainly at the card yes
worried about war soulless doll's eyes
laughed a little bit but yeah well they
had to yeah they were laughing at not
even punch lines well they were about to
drop cash from the ceiling so wow lead
with that all right speaking of that was
incredibly entertaining that brings us
to this week's entertainment minute
foreign
was dead to begin with Billy eichner's
new gay romantic comedy Bros
flopped oh I'm as surprised as you are
in the opening weekend now is it because
all romantic comedies are gay nope
it's it's subliminally gay but yes this
is explicitly gay right yeah that seems
to be the primary mistake so before we
get into why it flopped and you can
comment below as to your hunch why you
think it may have flopped let's just
take a look at some clips from again the
homosexual romantic comedy Bros Love Is
Love Is Love we can do whatever and we
can do it whenever does that work for
you yeah that definitely by the way if
your kids they shouldn't be watching
whenever whenever GIF of Michael Scott
dancing
it's good office gift this person isn't
gay or is he a top or bottom what does
that have to do with anything maybe
you're both bottoms and that's a problem
I'm not always the bottom Edgar
oh
ah what's that the violation of
expectation oh hey I'm gonna go oh
that's why I said if you have kids don't
watch this okay so you probably already
commented as to why you think it didn't
work yeah yeah by the way I don't think
that people would be you they wouldn't
picture it to be very romantic if it was
just like a straight orgy
no
it's not a lot of whining and dining no
going on so much as just group sex with
strange men we also have 20 hot women
came over to stop two hot women from
fighting right you'd probably think that
was sexist yes you would yeah it depends
where you are if it's a WNBA you'd be
like well sure I don't know and that's
it those guys were hot but I do yeah
well oh geez what do you think how do
you think they got cast here's the thing
it didn't work flopped okay
and that that should be fine it wouldn't
be a big deal if it just flopped okay
fine who cares the problem is now they
have to berate you the audience member
is it raining this here's another thing
is there a cat on the roof uh Billy
Eichner blamed straight people meaning
uh the primary audience because even if
all gay people want to go say it
wouldn't be enough he said uh that's
just the world we live in unfortunately
even with growing reviews great Rotten
Tomato scores and an a cinema score Etc
straight people especially in parts of
the country just didn't want to show up
for Bros and that's disappointing but it
is what it is that's right it is
also you bought those because they're
bought and paid for refused yes
yes but I spent the money Oh you mean a
bunch of other gays on uh Rotten
Tomatoes you know qualified or verified
reviewers liked your film but the
average American did not surprise and by
the way that's an interesting thesis but
for the IMDb page this is what Eichner
said before the film hmm co-writer and
star Billy Eichner have expressed that
he does not want conservatives
especially those who voted for the 45th
president of the United States and their
Associates to see the film deal even
conservatives who identify as being part
of the lgbtq plus Community as he views
them as Traders well there you go you
not only cut off half the country but
you've now cut off a significant portion
of gays because you're a hot there's a
big difference between a Hollywood gay
Hollywood gay guy and the average middle
American gay guy they're not on board
with all of the lgbtqaaip plus gay
William is an example A lot of them say
this has gone too far they want to live
their lives they want to be gay and they
don't want to you know be they don't
want to be the victim of a hate crime
and we all agree with that but you just
cut you cut them out you cut out half
the country sorry less than half the 70
million to 900 million votes for Joe
Biden that's true former Vice President
Joe Biden and you've cut out gay people
who disagree with anything you view and
you now are confused as to why it
flopped well also you don't think
there's enough of gay people in America
to create a hit film in an audience
right have you ever been been to a film
school or anything there's a lot of gay
people the entire independent film
industry is filled with gay people Plus
movies and Moonstruck is the gayest
movie
never maybe no not maybe no it is yes
well what's interesting is he had a
bunch of guys who looked pretty fit
right in this movie four gay people and
he did a lot of stuff to make it you
know titilizing for them I guess or
titillating sorry titillating
titillating things yes guys got tits on
the brain he did that and he still
managed to turn gay people off yes Boys
Don't Cry one that's true I mean there's
plenty of moves about gays it's because
it's it's the movie boat trip with just
guys having sex yeah it's like who would
have thought that a homosexual bachelor
party wouldn't be tapping into the pulse
of mainstream America right it's just a
dead genre yeah
but it's I guess two pies yes put them
together and pretend it's a butt
what token Allen uh so Kevin dug up a
tweet from 2017 where this might explain
another giant audience that Billy
Eichner I uh I missed that I was still
laughing the butt pies blow it up there
yeah so in 2017 he said I am anti-white
well
a lot of blaming with this guy yeah yeah
and by the way
romantic comedies don't really work
because of how men think okay there's no
there's no dance of Seduction that's not
how it works we have you been to a gay
bar it's a meat market it's not wooing
it's not oh I don't know and you have to
pursue it's just you it's just the
answer is yeah a woman's a woman
starting off point their default Point
as it comes to sex and relationships not
all generally speaking is men are
pursuing them and their default set
point is no or not yet a man's default
set point is please
when you have two guys and by the way we
actually have an early cut just to kind
of drive this point home of the movie
that was it was this is the realistic
version hmm so
want to have sex
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
I particularly love the Guess Who
character wig yeah I don't know why that
guy chose that why did I get a credit
why were you there on set I was not yes
you were you didn't think we didn't see
you in the bush is not a binoculars
you were totally thinks he's fooling
anyone uh and by the way he's a wife and
kids
this doesn't mean by the way that there
isn't hope for the uh uh the homosexual
rom-com genre because there have been
many a lot of you and that brings us to
this week's uh well the upcoming gay ROM
comes there's a big Market that brings
us to this week seven plus one
all right
yo forgot fifan in the chamber
and this one got away from us so there's
a Reload
refractory period is just ridiculous if
you think of any other office did this
around a conference table no one would
be working today
for us it's like that's perfect let's
add it all right seven plus one upcoming
gay rom-coms number seven Dave must love
dongs hmm there you go
hit the bullets a little I think this
sounds a little bit low uh number six uh
gay ROM comes how to lose your T cells
in 10 days
Gerald number five oh thank you a [ __ ]
to remember yeah
there's our favorite intimacy supervisor
that's him caulk Top gay ROM comes
number four my big fat gay Nordic Music
Festival
if that happened
I'll grab number three and then Gerald
can grab number two and Dave uh number
three top gay ROM comes there's
something about Gary it's HIV well
that's oh that's too long on the title
scary isn't scary
number two Gerald crazy stupid Lube well
there's nothing stupid about that it's
just prudent just consider it almost and
uh the number one well before the reload
uh number one uh upcoming gay rom-coms
Dave pretty Instinct oh that's not
that's too much okay hey by the way
reload
number seven
upcoming gay rom-coms and you can by the
way you can hit the like button if uh
you can hit the like button even if you
don't like it we don't care uh number
seven as goo as it gets oh gosh
that's a good one that's a cool one
one of the gay ghosts say the other
ghost oh
[Laughter]
number six Dave
uh Four Weddings and a bunch of funerals
yes
again these are 14 plus one they're
these are these are already they're in
production they've been optioned yeah no
don't blame us number five this one has
actually I was confused number five uh
upcoming is Mamma Mia oh sorry Mamma Mia
my ass hurts
because you didn't go probably and my
ass hurts that's part three split in
three yes
top upcoming gay rom-coms number four
Gerald uh 10 Things I Hate About vaginas
well that makes sense
Top gay rom-coms again they've been
optioned uh number three uh immune
systemless in Seattle
that one seems a little bit Curt as well
it's a little blunt but well he did
technically make that movie yes yes he
did uh and uh top upcoming rom-coms
number two Dave uh When Harry Met Sally
who used to be Carl
he's gonna want to be discriminated
right no you have to and uh the number
one upcoming gay rom-com we're all
excited about uh you've got AIDS
oh by the way the plus one uh cats
oh yeah that's cats
[Music]
yo forgot the fan in the chamber
oh by the way I should mention this with
the uh food shortages going on there you
know they're a wonderful sponsor to the
show uh don't wait for an emergency to
come up you have a three months food
supply if you go to prep with
crowder.com you get 20 off a three-month
food supply uh prep with credit I come I
actually have eaten all the oatmeal they
need to send me more they do need to
send you more that's good stuff it's way
better than Quaker Oats yeah we by the
way for that seven we had more oh yeah
we talked about like a lot more monkey
pox yes would have worked really well
obviously holes
I'm so mad we didn't get 12 monkey pox
in there
it's not a romantic comedy yeah it's
more of a gay sci-fi you're right yeah
there's a debate for that one yeah
holes we just didn't we couldn't change
the name no exactly I mean not to
mention there were three back to the
[ __ ] boys it was just one of those
things
[Laughter]
kids but here's the issue right and by
the way we'll get to Hocus Pocus on Mud
Club
you can't escape it you know it used to
be separate the art from the artist but
it is so aggressive now that it's
impossible to simply enjoy the art
because the art is a byproduct it is a
it's a canvas painted by these artists
and unfortunately now everything has
been politicized you can't go and enjoy
films at the cinema can I give you one
more tweet from Billy eckner
[Laughter]
a few months ago get your fictional
hateful Bible stories and your fake
fictional religious BS out of our effing
lives FU oh well you know wow maybe a
little prayer would have got a better
boxer
he's a top he's a he's a Talent little
homo yes wow
maybe this is karma be tolerant and
agree with everything I say how I say it
or we will remove your ability to make a
living and what I just said a tolerant
homosexual will be considered more
offensive than he said f your fake Bible
and your fictional stories and F you
whatever he could have fixed every house
in Florida with just the parade budget
for that movie yes
did you see the commercial it's just a
parade yeah I know well come on
what is he gonna he's not was he gonna
do a gay romantic comedy and not have a
parade well that's true it's mainly just
parade that's like a chick flick where
it's not a romantic comedy of the women
and they don't have some kind of a you
know dance party while cooking yeah
that's true yeah
oh it's on me like oh who who who could
possibly understand why women's content
doesn't appeal to men but the content
that appeals to men is often Universal
I've never once had a batter baking Food
Fight Party Never I've never once
spilled something in the kitchen without
a woman yelling at me let alone her
doing it oh yeah they get abusive yes
that's an Oxo commercial that you won't
see for their kitchen supplies I like
the brand Oxo their stuff is great so
let's get to Biden
it's better than what are you a
KitchenAid guy I just didn't know how
you pronounced it that way okay what is
it supposed to be he's a Bravo guy is it
Oxo or Oxo I have no idea it's all caps
can someone comment it's hard it's like
oh it's so like that
look from them basically when I get
through stuff like if it's a ladle it's
just their stuff is always better you're
gonna lead with meat tenderizer after
that segment yes yes yes that's exactly
why exactly what it's for yes
I have the blade meat tenderizer yeah
right in his forehead I know
he'd like it yeah bring it he looked
like one of those kids toys where you
put your hand through the pins
all right so let's get to The Germ
needles yes
show what I'm talking about yes you just
love those things yes yeah well you know
what you can be a walking those things
like the one you did at KV toys and it
gave everyone pink eye yes I remember
when you put your face on it you're like
oh that was a dumb idea that's exactly
uh all right so former Vice President
Joe Biden okay this is hilarious but it
also was indicative of the left
pandering and there's a silver lining
like I've said this is a good thing they
are so out of touch they don't realize
all of the people they're turning off
namely black people Latinos and yes a
record number of gays so uh former Vice
President Joe Biden pandered to the
people of Puerto Rico on Monday uh
telling them that all of America is with
you well that's nice as they how they
were cut they're recovering from a
hurricane obviously hurricane Fiona I
don't like it they named it Fiona by the
way but that's story for another day
see if you can spot the moment that
here's the thing everyone lies anyone
who says they don't lie that's a lie
like everyone lies with us to not hurt
somebody's feelings or every now like
small little lies everyone has engaged
in small little white lying the problem
and politicians certainly most of them
lie Joe Biden lies about ever and he
lies when he has no reason to lie and he
doesn't just lie in exact like Donald
Trump would exaggerate sometimes Donald
Trump would exaggerate or diminish right
he would just turn everything up to an
11 or if it was a three turn it down to
a one to insult his opponent Joe Biden
makes up stories that never happened
with people he never met in places that
don't even exist see if you can spot the
blatant lie in his uh Puerto Rico
Centric speech ever since the hurricane
struck Jill and I have had people in
Puerto Rico on our minds and in our
prayers we came here in person to show
that we're with you Amer all of America
is with you as you receive and recover
and rebuild I come from below the state
the little state of Delaware it's not
like the congressman from New York seeks
of the big States but we have a in
relative terms large Puerto Rican
population in Delaware relative to our
population did you spot it we have the
eighth largest black population in the
country and between all minorities we
have 20 percent of our state is minority
and so I is a minority I uh was sort of
raised in the Puerto Rican community at
home yeah yeah yeah he was
it's a no it's a very Puerto Rican uh
Centric State all 0.39 of them when he's
talking about penguins wow the first I
can go back the 1970 uh census you can
go to a lot of cutter.com for all the
references or click the link in the
description
0.39 you wouldn't even have enough to
create the Sharks yeah right I had a
gardener I saw through my window yeah
right at the beginning he's like all
right so Puerto Rican and then he's like
well I got to loot black people in there
somehow and the Puerto rican's like how
does this matter I don't know why he's
talking about black people in his State
yes you know they're all in that group
of I don't want to talk yeah yeah
there's so many minorities yes lots and
lots of minorities Oh by God I do know
that New York is bigger than Delaware
now thank you that was helpful I mean
there's done near 20 minorities and 80
white hence making them a minority it's
really at the top of my mind when it
comes to natural disasters but you know
the Haiti earthquake I went down to help
yes so many damn minorities mostly
Haitians Hunter came with us and Boyd he
didn't bring condoms no he did not he
did throw a gun in a dumpster though
again
every time he sees a dumpster he wants
to throw a gun so he says I was raised
in a largely Puerto Rican Community it's
Delo and first off again it doesn't pass
a sniff test you right away if you go
Delaware I think so correct go with your
gut if your gut says former Vice
President Joe Biden is lying it's
0.39
comment below if if you thought it was a
little higher looks like in Wayne's
World where they're going through the
states and they'll have something and
they get to Delaware and they're like
we're in Delaware Delaware yeah
damn in Texas Wayne yeah
I'm in Delaware that's it yeah there's
nothing there I think there's no state
tax I don't know yeah that's it but uh
this brings us to actually the top five
times that Democrats have been caught
pandering and this is why black voters
are turning off to them in uh record
numbers so number five if you don't
remember this Kamala Harris this is not
an exception is what I want to make sure
you understand because we see these
things and you see them in isolated and
said ah he misspoke he didn't misspeak
he lied he made it up to try and Pander
for votes to be clear and this is what
the Democrat Party does it's really hard
to compete with people who simply lie
and they know the media will carry their
water anyone out there anyone see on CNN
this morning did they call him on it did
they call him to the mat on it no of
course MSNBC NBC ABC CBS did they say
and I don't mean that they say uh Joe
Biden maybe had a slip that uh is not
fully corrected they say this guy is a
compulsive liar that's your job
as the media
I would say Cronkite would have done it
but he was a raging leftist too there
never was objective journalism in this
country so let's go to number five these
are the times they've pandered uh we'll
make all these uh available Kamala
Harris where she talked about uh smoking
weed with uh Charlemagne uh the god uh
self self title have you ever smoked I
have okay and I inhale I did it I did
inhale
it was a long time ago but yeah
asking about the mayor
[Laughter]
all right
you're getting the picture this is not
going to be comfortable for the next
time we're listening to Tupac yes she
was listening to Tupac Tupac was oh yeah
why don't we have that clip after
listening to Tupac and Biggie well after
Tupac and big we'll bring it up
afterwards we'll get the Tupac clip they
were both six yes
they were still spitting at Dave they
died at 25 and 24 I think here's that by
the way Hillary Clinton here's another
one number four Hillary Clinton again
this is the pandering that they do
usually to Black voters uh where she
said and it's not as bad as number three
Hillary Clinton talking about how she
brings hot sauce with her everywhere of
course when she's speaking to her
African-American cistern no more
questions they said no she has to go
what's something that you always carry
with you hot sauce
really yeah yeah really are you getting
in formation right now
hot sauce in my bag swag that's us
really yes now listen I just want you to
know people are going to see this and
say okay
okay is it working
well we know it wouldn't be salt because
that would render your powers and hurt
why wouldn't you prove it then yeah okay
hot sauce you got hot sauce in your bag
swag hot sauce I already said hot sauce
don't ask me other things why are you
sandbagging me she says every racist
food
giblets
color green
our bags just full of mail
yes the whitest most awful just a
cucumber sandwiches
[Laughter]
almonds
here's number three because Hillary
Clinton is just the worst at this but
you know you have to Pander when you're
completely talentless and unlikable
here's when she actually put up a fake
black voice in case you've forgotten I
don't feel no way he's tired
I'm too far
[Applause]
from nobody told me that the road would
be easy
don't believe he brought me this far to
leave me
oh wow I forgot that was in Selma
Alabama and it makes it so much worse
it's way way worse next things you're
actually gonna do a Sam Kinison
impression oh
buddy
is it that uh is it that little Arkansas
what's up
because that's you know he was imitating
a priest he's a southern preacher okay
Sam Kennedy he came from a family of
preachers exactly yeah exactly and what
is Darnell shut the brakes taken out
she's the worst
I would have loved to see her face when
it was like uh Donald Trump won
did he Pander better than I did can you
imagine the shock my personal favorite
but it's not number one number two was
when uh if you don't remember this
Pelosi Kamala and a lot of members of
Congress they were wearing the African
Garb and the scarves and remember this
happened when we were live on air yeah
it was live on air and I said oh my gosh
I can't believe they're doing that
seriously and they caught a little bit
of flack for appropriation but certainly
not enough they were bowing and thanking
George Floyd for justice but the
funniest part is the the uh Desmond Tutu
you know uh uh Swatch Sydney Poitier in
White Man's Burden they call me Mrs
[ __ ]
number four
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
it's a Cause
for sacrificing your life for justice
my favorite part of that was help I've
knelt and I can't get up
I literally did
protest of functioning hips yes
someone hit me up thank you for
sacrificing your life I'm sure he wasn't
a big fan of it it was Dylan's car just
crashes into it was he from Africa I
don't think he was
I believe he was from Minneapolis yes
Cup Foods that's where he resided so uh
and this brings us to number one just
because we watched this in real time
when there were these debates and the
reason this is because it's dueling
pandering yes where I want you to look
at Booker's face where he's upset
that Beto has out pandered him
this economy has got to work for
everyone and right now we know that it
isn't and it's going to take all of us
coming together to make sure that it
does neces
that's like when Chelsea Handler we all
know this this is kind of a secret in
the industry Open Secret is has Chelsea
Handler have people on the show would
pre-tape it and then use their jokes
that's like it's like having an opener
go out and steal your joke and Beto's
just like sorry Booker's like oh that's
that's my bit he's like that's my bit
did he did he also find out about
Rosetta Stone
I'm from Newark of course I speak
Spanish
I was raised with a lot of Puerto Ricans
actually they probably are in Newark you
would actually have a claim to it no uh
and by the way that brings us to Pony if
you missed this when the debate happened
we actually I think created this that
night lived in debate and had it before
the end uh was uh uh the dueling uh Beto
and uh Booker we thought it was so funny
that we actually put way too much
production value into an anime
representation
so what would you do how to spend day
one at the White House
invested
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
comment below you got him you got AOC
how much Spirit cooking causes the
googly eye
get the exact amount because I can't get
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I can't get
that we don't want to show up
googly-head one day you seen you know
what maybe you guys can bring this up in
the control room uh Cory Booker always
tries to do these motivational speeches
on his Instagram like a wise man once
told me that there was a man who this is
one that I remember specifically he says
he asked his master he
wanted to learn from me he saw his
master meditating across the river and
he couldn't find a way to the river and
he's like all sweaty like he's jogging
and he said master master and he stopped
meditating he said how do I get to the
other side of the river and he said
Young Apprentice you're already there
and video you're like this sucks I hate
you yeah
a smart person makes something
complicated sound easy it is I just did
the opposite of that by the way here's a
lone star I'm high already there do you
remember when he had his Spartacus
moment where he announced something that
was already public information yeah it
was like this is brand new stuff no
because if you want to show a little
humility compare yourself to Spartacus
yeah if I if I get kicked out of
Congress for this so be it sir we
released that at noon I know but if I
get kicked out of Congress for saying
this right and use as many quotes as
possible because you've never had a
thought of your own that made sense
right in Espanol
[Laughter]
maybe I'll need to incorporate some
Booker I have a bunch of Booker material
uh in Oklahoma City that's uh this
Saturday October 8th I have a sixth and
an 8 45 show because man I have like so
many notes in Cory book and it's just
it's just I'm like well I don't think
enough people know how crappy he is it
would require too much explanation we're
gonna say they're uh we got the Kamala
Harris clip about Tupac oh yeah this
one's great this should have been number
five but they're they're both uh equally
um I mean comfortable they want to make
you throw it yeah
what does Kamala Harris listen to what
were you listening to when you was high
what was on what's wrong oh my goodness
oh yeah definitely Snoop uh Tupac for
sure
Liar Liar [ __ ] you know it
talking about [ __ ] and Juice
I'm just doing the math
rolling down the street she's smoking in
though
sipping on Jan Andrews that's right I'm
laid back hey I'm Kamala and I'm here to
sing yeah sending your money to Ukraine
in a major way yes
what a stupid world I don't know what we
used to mock you know people used to
mock Christian rightfully so many of
them Christians for being out of touch
like we're gonna do our we're gonna do
our youth sermon through hip-hop they're
doing that only with adults and it's
half the country and a portion of you
buy it
yeah the cool uh yeah the cool youth
pastor who sits on a chair like AC
Slater and it's like you've lost me yes
pulls up a stool let's talk yeah I
remember I had a youth pastor who
thought that uh he thought we were all
like six so he'd feel like like you'd
play gross games like you know like oh
do like the Halloween thing where you
have like a bowl of spaghetti I'm like
we're we're 15. yeah we've done this for
10 years already want us to play a game
we have to drink soda through the next
guy's sock I was like or you're not a
team player I'm like I don't need a
drink through a tube sock for Jesus this
is gross I'm 16 years old I'm only here
because of the girls yeah you're like oh
then uh just use two fingers in the
spaghetti yes
also do you know where this guy's sock
was did I mention we were 15. yes thing
stands up oh he already put the can of
coconut no it's just standing on its own
yeah it does it doesn't leak at all
weird I've got one of those weird Cory
Booker motivational speeches if you want
to see it like behind the paywall mug
club or yes let's see it behind the
paywall because it's just it's going to
be too much we've overloaded you and by
the way hit the like button if you want
more of those sketches the anime stuff
because it takes a lot of work to make a
show that's stupid So speaking
speaking of pandering CNN now and if
they're forced to admit something that
is harmful to Democrats then you know
must be really bad they've admitted that
black voters are in very large numbers
leaving the party and then I want to
again it's not what you read but it's
what is being omitted because CNN acted
in unison with the New York Times but
they tried to take the edge off of how
bad it really is here's CNN's admission
look black voters are the part the core
part of the democratic party and as you
can see here in the race for congress
look you're still getting 74 support in
the pre-election polling right now but
compare that to the final polling for
2020 president and 2018 Congress back in
2020 it was 84 85 in 2018. so you're
clearly seeing right here that there is
less support for Democratic candidates
for congress among African Americans
okay now bring up the collage that we
have for the New York Times They also
covered this and I don't know you know
what just like we ask what are the
chances of all major social media
platforms removing Alex Jones within the
same 24-hour period what are the chances
that you have all these news agencies
running this story
at the same time within let's say 48
Hours of each other three days of each
other the same week and only going back
the exact amount the exact period of
time so they all go back to 2018.
interesting and even though there's a
look 85 so it's pretty bad enough it's
in the 70s yeah okay where else do you
see polling that just goes back to a
primary you don't even go back to the
last national election let's look at the
numbers they're even worse for Democrats
again the trend is what matters here
let's go past 2018 in 2016. 88 Lex
supported Democrats versus eight percent
Republican you go back even further
2012. 93 of blacks were Democrats
collected 2008 95 so 2008 to now we've
gone from 95 what was the most recent
over there there's 75 yeah 75 95 to 75.
if you just go back to 2018 well it
seems like okay this could be a problem
if you actually understand 2008 you go
back that far too today you say we are
hemorrhaging voters it's not starting to
be a problem it's already a problem not
to mention Latino voters we've talked
about that in the past oh yeah and by
the way also if you go back to for
example depending on how far back you go
and this is the problem we have all
references available at lottery.com
um you can make something look however
you want it to look for example if you
go back to 1863 uh 100 of blacks were
Republicans
[Laughter]
it's all context folks
they really had the platform yes
and uh one black vote of course who is
angered uh the left very much is Kanye
West yesterday at the the Yeezy I think
it's the season nine I didn't remember
the season
season nine of Yeezy there's a show in
Paris he wore a shirt with the words
White lives matter ah and then the other
non-democrat Candace Owens also appeared
with Kanye wearing the matching shirt
white lives matter
um naturally of course the uh uh failed
ESPN host Jim L Hill decided to take the
Twitter to criticize Kanye he said so
many black folks are trying to excuse
Kanye wearing a white lives matter
t-shirt as just a troll mover marketing
maybe it is but it's a dangerously dumb
message to send for people with his
massive platform I've been off dude but
y'all go ahead labeling his foolishness
as genius here's the thing Kanye West's
genius didn't change back when the show
was syndicated on radio so I think in
2014 I almost YouTube then I was in a
care on radio and then went back to you
know mug Club
um
turn on uh All of the Lights was the uh
the final song because it was morning
and I was going so I've always been and
I used to get crap for it I've always
been a fan Kanye's a brilliant MC I've
liked hip-hop I can I've disagreed again
I've separated the art from the artist
with Kanye West I did that for a very
long time right I think he's a [ __ ]
because back then he said George W Bush
George Bush doesn't care about black
people say well that's a stupid thing to
say whether you're a fan of George Bush
no one's a fan of fish whether you hate
George Bush or not to say that he
doesn't care about black people is just
not accurate the guy appointed more
black people to his cabinet than at that
point I believe any other president in
history I'm I could be off by a little
bit but it was certainly close
so I was able to separate the art from
the artist for some reason though they
have to try and wipe out memory hole the
fact that Kanye is one of the most
prolific hip-hop artists of Our
Generation why because he thinks
incorrectly what's so dangerous they say
dangerous what's dangerous about a black
man saying that white lives matter it's
only dangerous to be bind to the leftist
lie that anything other than black lives
matter which by the way was a trademark
black lives matter if you look at the
non-profits and you look at the
embezzling that took place you look at
people who've actually been charged
convicted
with fraudulent Financial crimes uh with
the black lives matter organization if
you don't buy what they sell wholesale
black lives matter anything else is
considered racist anything else is
considered white supremacy not only
white lives matter all lives matter
what's considered white supremacy
so he's him and Candace Owens must be
some of those those black white
supremacists there's more of them than
we thought but you're right it's the
same the shirt could be any color right
and that's the whole reason that we said
whoa whoa don't do that that actually
can be racist how about just all lives
matter all lives matter we can all get
behind let's just make sure that all
lives matter that make sure that no life
is below another life that should be
common ground for everybody
that all lives don't matter let's not be
stupid but but putting that on the back
of a shirt it it should at least show
like oh are you triggered by that well
then think about how other people felt
for the last five years right it's like
oh white people weren't dying yeah they
were Asians weren't dying yeah they were
Hispanics weren't dying yeah they were
aware and just think of the difference
in the reaction of something like the
piss Christ or reactions to you know
people comedians who would go out there
and it's a comedic Witch Hunt you know
Donald Trump he's Putin's cockholster
from Colbert are you like hey look we're
sticking it to the man what by making
fun of white heterosexual Christians oh
boy yeah you're really you're really
treading some new ground there but if a
black black person goes out and says hey
White lives matter well hold on a second
this is a risk I thought art was about
taking risk I thought art was about
holding up a mirror which is what he's
doing Society it's not acceptable they
don't want edgy they want parroting of
the propaganda talking points that to me
is what's most important to see here we
always hear about these artists I want
to be free to be an artist we just had
Billy Eichner say F you after your Bible
I don't want you to go see my movie if
you're a heterosexual if you're a
conservative Trump voter Kanye West Hey
look obviously it's it's
elicited a reaction a response from you
guys
what happened to Art being edgy what
happened to Art being risky and honestly
I cannot remember I I genuinely and you
guys can look I can't remember white
pundits white reporters
white anyone in the public sphere
brutally attacking I mean just just
incessantly attacking any kind of a
public figure who was black they always
tread very carefully with the exception
being that they are a conservative once
that happens you're treated just like a
a white guy and it's open season
yeah they're doing it right now with I
mean first person that comes to mind is
Herschel Walker whether he deserves it
or not different story but he's a
conservative very outspoken he's decided
to do that they did it with Larry Elder
in California the first you know white
layout is probably a better example yeah
it's a better example herself Walker I'm
not agreeing with I'm just saying you're
making the point that they wouldn't do
that for a Democrat they're not doing it
for Stacy Abrams with all the stupid
stuff that she's doing right right
they're doing it to Herschel Walker
because he's a conservative repeatedly
used the n-word in front of Jean-Pierre
like he did Clarence Thomas no not
saying he called him the n-word but he
used Dennis is the other one yeah pretty
grossly in front of him yes in front of
him yeah that's a really awful clip he
used it when he didn't have to use it
that's exactly it and I don't believe
that the n-word is one thing that's
completely off limits if it's said in
context or for example of course I'm a
big fan of Kanye you don't think that
I've said it when singing along by
myself in my car to cut to a College
Dropout that's an appreciation for his
art I wouldn't walk up and say it to a
black person Joe Biden did if he didn't
say that he did it with Clarence Thomas
right there in front of his face
extraordinarily liberal really right
yeah yes yes it was really it was just
float off it really was talking like
it's comfortable man yeah yeah I I that
was one of those clips where it just it
really bothers me that anybody would be
like this guy is the voice for the black
people Ben Carson Hermann yeah
Condoleezza Rice anybody who happens to
disagree and is black yeah can you
handle these rice got dragged over oh
yes oh man she really did and by the way
just before we leave uh this isn't just
an issue with uh Black Americans the
pandering and this is the thing I think
it's particularly a an issue with black
Americans because think about it you
hear them all the time say keep it real
you hear that in in hip-hop all the time
and white people for the longest time I
don't know what that means keep it real
there is a value of authenticity in the
black community that's why you're able
to actually have conversations with them
that don't necessarily just turn into a
screeching match unlike white liberals
um keep it real they value authenticity
they can sense when something is
completely inauthentic like those clips
that we just showed you and I would say
to uh maybe a lesser extent but I still
certainly would say Hispanics obviously
value authenticity and their support for
Democrats has been cut in half in the
past decade this is according to an NBC
Telemundo poll uh 54 of Latino voter
surveyed said they prefer Democrats to
be in charge of Congress compared with
33 percent who would prefer Republicans
uh that Gap is only 21 points now was a
42 Point difference in October 2012 and
there are some municipalities we've
covered in Texas that are in Arizona
where they a majority of Hispanics
support Republicans yeah what do you
think is going to happen if they
continue losing using the term latinx
it's not going to get any better the own
as a matter of fact the only Democrat
group stronghold that has increased the
only one that has consistently increased
take a guess hey before you if you're
watching I'm going to pause and if
you're if you're not watching live pause
it
okay I want you to comment below which
group do you think both sex and race
you want drum roll yeah give me a drum
roll
that was fast
white Suburban [ __ ]
exclusively saw that one coming
well there's not all of you watching
because I can say look our white lady in
the suburbs I'm obviously not talking
about you but that's the problem if you
take it personally it's statistical
reality go ahead go ahead and clean a
house yourselves white Suburban women
you need to speak up more because your
neighbors suck go ahead yeah I was going
to say Hispanics I'm not surprised by
that because everybody my sister's
married to a guy who's from his family's
from Mexico they still live down on the
border um near sapata right yeah they
talk about this other people talk about
this they're the ones that don't like
the immigration policy like don't have
open borders like this this is crazy
this is leading to people dying left and
right and coyotes
killing people leaving them in trucks to
die in the heat if the police could like
this is leading to really bad things in
a fake tunnel yeah I don't know how I
got it I don't know how those coyotes
got a driver's license that's weird who
knew right no but they hate that and so
Dems are pushing the wrong policies
across the board for these groups
thinking that they can Pander enough to
these groups and win them over they're
not even pandering in the right way no
well because that depended to too many
different groups you know who doesn't
really like abortion up until including
birth period Catholic Hispanics yeah you
know who doesn't like trans male to
female athletes competing in women's
sports
no not white not white Suburban [ __ ]
that Gary Oldman quote is almost always
appropriate almost but not in this
instance
black women no you know what more black
women compete in sports and certainly
compete in sports at the highest level
and so they understand the difference
they're not for it black women not no
group of men are for it black women
weren't for it I didn't know I've never
seen the numbers on Hispanic women I'm
sure they probably weren't for trans
male athletes competing women's sports
women white women the vast majority of
whom do not compete at in sports in a
high level said no you have to do it to
be nice no that is the only and they
have uh of unfortunately
disproportionately large amount of power
that they wield at school boards they
they will administratively same thing
that you have in churches and it's not
representative of women of all other
races and the disconnect that is taking
place between the Democratic party and
what they claim to have been their core
voting base has changed and so now the
only people to whom they can Pander are
white Suburban women those are the only
people who are buying the woke [ __ ]
those are the only people who are
watching steaming piles of dog crap like
Hocus Pocus 2 and three more us three we
have to do a review for this on mug Club
lot of credit.com we're going to go
there do that review take your chats
please consider joining up uh you get an
extra full 100 of show and uh usually
things it's it's basically a torture
test share it if you're watching right
now on YouTube Rumble we love you
appreciate you Rumble YouTube we don't
love you matter of fact it's I would say
it's a love-hate relationship it's a
hate hate relationship piss off
foreign
[Music]